we have now learned about a us-led
Special Forces operation which was
carried out in central Yemen Saturday
against al-qaeda this was Donald Trump's
first military operation it was planned
by the Pentagon for months it was
ultimately authorized by Donald Trump
President Obama had refused to approve
this attack just ten days before leaving
office because the Pentagon wanted to do
it on a moonless night which wasn't
going to happen until Trump was in
office to provide more cover of darkness
al Qaeda had been made aware of the
approach of US forces before this
hour-long firefight and this ultimately
led to the death of u.s. Navy SEAL
William Owens who was killed along with
three others who were wounded in that
attack and there was also a Marine Corps
aircraft damaged which had to be
destroyed the US Defense Department
reported that 14 al Qaeda fighters were
killed including three prominent figures
the US military had originally denied
that there were any civilian casualties
it was later reported that up to 30
civilians were killed as a result of
aerial gunfire including at least eight
women and including at least seven
children the Yemen foreign minister said
the extrajudicial killings and killing
civilians are condemned acts that
support terrorism here is the really
crazy thing we have now learned it
appears as though Donald Trump casually
approved this military raid with only
limited information about it over dinner
and this sort of took a back some
military intelligence experts who then
the next day went through their own
internal discussion of the raid but it
was really kind of irrelevant because
Trump had already approved it really
really quickly in a way that presidents
typically don't approve these things and
as far as the reports that are coming
out of this dinner go it is incredibly
disturbing that Donald Trump is making
these decisions so casually I mean it
just just picture at Trump sitting there
with a Jared Kushner and I don't
remember if it was Steve Bannon or what
which other adviser was there
Reince Priebus or whoever
just sort of having dinner and saying
yeah let's do it and of course the
military saying well we would normally
go into much more detail you could you
you would potentially be in the
Situation Room all this is going on it's
also been reported that Trump wasn't
even in the Situation Room while this
was going on and a lot of people are
saying that this may have gone
differently if Trump was in the
Situation Room I don't really know
whether that's the case it seems to me
that if you're actually conducting a
military operation you probably want
Trump as far away from it as possible
the more hands-off Trump is probably the
better but it's more about Trump
couldn't even be bothered to be in the
Situation Room
during the raid this was confirmed by
press secretary Sean Spicer who said
Trump was here in the presidential
residence and the morning after the raid
before addressing the fact that there
were American casualties before
addressing anything else about the
operation Donald Trump decided it maybe
not surprisingly to go to war with the
media about this tweeting quote somebody
with aptitude and conviction should buy
the fake news and failing New York Times
and either run it correctly or let it
fold with dignity
is there anything presidential about
this folks I mean we have here a
president who it's casually approving
raids that are leading to the deaths of
dozens of people with as yet unproven
benefit when it comes to the
intelligence that was recovered not able
to be bothered to be in the Situation
Room all this is going on and then the
first public statement that Trump
chooses to make about this is about
quote fake news from the New York Times
based on their report of the raid
not exactly supporting the troops is it
this is incredibly disturbing and I
really hope you would think that even
the Warhawk neoconservatives would be
concerned with this because they claim
to want to support the troops I know
that that's become code for basically
send troops into as many military
engagements as possible and put a yellow
ribbon on your car or fridge but if you
really support the true
you would condemn the way that Donald
Trump handled and reacted to this